I wrap it it yeah all right it for me
yes oh you guys it everyone's gonna
comment how bad I am at this game now
damn it
yeah this map is hurt yeah it hurt my
job Ken I don't even get a sigh did it
yes yes I'm here guys
no what uh-oh what how am I gonna get up
there how in the heavens win there oh
god guys it does not get better that's
is here we go yeah hello oh yes
God well it doesn't I am damaged piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] a bit [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
we should go to easier when a yes can i
but I don't pick the rabbit then we can
talk all right
everyone has the proper bike let's go
GTA I'm waiting on it for sweet it
America no no ah ah yes yes ah gonna win
this for Abba and IKEA and then I'm
gonna have some meat fry Kia in my
camper yeah oh we get to pick rabbit
rabbit got it yeah X alright I lied are
you you didn't bring rabbit ah [ __ ]
feed haha what a what a jerk yeah I got
have to wait for you guys forever now I
literally can't get out oh dammit
cutting it oh my god it's so much easier
with a [ __ ] bike there are all bikes
can do it I can do it you're broke
you're too I go in oh oh oh yes
no no oh yeah
no it's not bad nah
Jack you son of a [ __ ] I knew backflips
truck wait everyone bailed for me okay
hey backwards
ooh not to [ __ ] I don't know any other I
don't know I'm out of here
hey guys did you like this swimming hey
I'm gonna win
Oh cry I'm gonna win cheater
ah yes wedding jack I just
hey hey my back my back I want to that
love I know you guys are away up there
oh wow how did that happen
yeah I'm good that's why [ __ ] oh look
at that I got it I got it
let's not flip how it's bled huh look at
that yeah yeah back flip ah [ __ ] all
back flips every jump oh yes that was a
perfect foot oh look at that friend yeah
yeah oh look at this thing whoever beats
this one wins all the subs I need the
Sharks yeah [ __ ] I'm so bad what the
hell go ah are you kidding me come on
make it make it [ __ ] kidding me
there we go there we go there we go
what's up peasants piece of shits oh I'm
stuck
let's [ __ ] stock stock stock ready
Jack come from with a wedding front left
Jack no - [ __ ] nowhere access video
RKO RKO RKO RKO out of nowhere Haley
again get so far wait up oh oh what's up
[ __ ] not gonna bug no mom
oh he's gonna back up a little bit come
on come on yes
what don't you want to find in your
clean ouch I don't in Michael Jackson's
final moment we thought about Justin
Bieber